hi my name is Dan Shapiro I am director
of the Harvard international negotiation
program and it's an honor to talk with
you all today in the YouTube community I
a global priority as I see it is to
build more effective processes
institution ways of dealing with
conflict conflict that has a huge cost
on our society today there was a recent
study done in the Middle East showing
that in the past 20 years the cost of
conflict has been approximately 12
trillion dollars 12 trillion dollars I
mean imagine with that region would look
like with a surplus of that nature with
the institution's can look like of
education and so on and that's just the
Middle East we look at the rest of the
world as well the cost of conflict is
huge and what can we do it on the
problem is that our world is very
focused right now on reacting to
conflict on dealing with it after the
fact assuming that destructive conflict
violent conflict is a natural state of
human being rather than saying what can
we do to try to prevent violent conflict
destructive conflict from occurring in
the first place and so myself and a
number of people a global agenda council
here at the World Economic Forum one
that focuses on negotiation colleagues
at Harvard are all in a concerted way
now working to build new models new ways
practically of preventing violent
conflict before it even occurs and one
of the things that I would encourage you
to do and all of us to do is to try and
build into our educational systems into
our institutions curricula trainings on
conflict resolution and negotiation so
that we can build the capacity for peace
and for people to deal with conflict
more effectively ultimately toward a
more secure and stable world so I look
forward to hearing all of the good work
that you're doing and thank you for
listening to me today